one of my favorites getting to know him
and his whole damn family and I say that
with the most most up most of respect
even though I did use the damn word
two-time Super Bowl champion 11 seasons
in the NFL and even better yet great
human on the planet Chris long how are
you Chris Ritz what's up man it's pretty
early in the the interview to cuss I
true I know later on normally it's later
on to three minutes in is when you
normally make people cuz right so what's
going on your world describe my describe
your life to me Chris what's going on in
your world right now a lot of family
time I thought I knew my kids very very
well I'm getting another millat better
and it's actually not bad being home I
mean I'm super sad about everything
of course I'm pretty bummed about you
know everything I see on the news all
the time but I do think there's a place
for sports right now and I think that
you know a lot of people making content
sports related content and stretching
that into pop culture is what I'm saying
a lot of people do in the list the
brackets always stuff it helps man I
think people need that right now so
trying to churn out as many pods as I
can I got my green light pod shameless
plug and we do it as much as we can and
how could people go grab that pod Chris
I think you just check it you know Apple
podcasts Spotify this search greenlight
pod I don't I don't listen to my pod a
lot because I hate my voice about you
know but Chris there is an iron-rich and
eysan i do love the sound of my voice
which is why I just went lower register
on you right there you know I don't mind
the sound of my voice but I don't listen
back or watch back a lot of what I do I
just that is that is except for a couple
interviews where I just want to make
sure that I heard the right thing cuz
I'm a perfectionist Chris just like I'm
sure you don't you know when it all
comes down for sure I just I just would
I would be losing my mind if I had to
listen myself fantastic Chris long here
on the Rich Eisen show
you saw up close the Brady Belichick
relationship for all those years
is there any credence to the fact that
Brady was never going back there that
there was just too long of a 20-year
quarterback coach relationship and he
just needed to turn the page no I mean
now that would be speculation on my part
I think even if you played there and I
was only there a year so right sometimes
when I talk about the Pats I feel even
I'm qualified because there were guys
that have been there a long long time
but Tom Tom was a great teammate treated
all the coaches with respect including
Bill and you know they had a
relationship that was interesting but
you know I don't think anybody really
knows what that relationship is truly
like and seeing them together doing that
top 100 thing was almost surreal and
such a relaxed place talking ball and
they certainly seemed fine there and I'm
sure they're fine but I think for Tom
it's a football decision as much as
anything when you looked at the Chargers
the Patriots and the Bucks
those were the three teams that were
being flouted the most towards the end
the Patriots weren't competitive
financially the charges I don't think
we're competitive relative to the Bucks
football was and I don't think any of
them were competitive football wise
relative to the Bucks and what and what
he could do in Tampa with the weapons he
has around him and that defense that I
expect to be very good so I think it was
the right football move for him the only
wrench in there is that this is the most
unique offseason of all time
you know if you're changing systems
especially if you've been in one place
20 years you might be the goat and you
might be inheriting LJ Howard Evans God
when that defense we talked about but
it's a change and I know him and Bruce
could face time all day but you got to
execute you got to have things like
minicamp OTAs you got a camp I don't
know what's gonna happen with that
interesting so there's a lot to unpack
there let me let me guess go one-by-one
seeing the relationship that you saw
with Bill and and Brady close up for
that one year to the point where you
said it was kind of surreal to see them
in a relaxed setting on the NFL 100 set
you should have tried just physically
being across the table from them on for
size to watch that old thing go down
and it was it was the first segment of
the entire series that we shot - so just
me sitting there seeing Bella check in
the role of analyst for the first time
and there's Tom Brady next to him and
the two of them kind of talking about
each other without actually you know
having the conversation yet because it
was just a dynamic everyone was trying
to feel out what it was like in a
television setting it was it was
interesting but how is that relationship
as you saw work different from say other
quarterback coach relationships and I
know nobody else is Brady nobody else is
a goat but how was it any different from
what you witnessed in your career well
it's interesting I mean if you were to
compare it to you know Drew Brees and
Peyton or you know any of the other
coach quarterback pairings that have
endured long periods I'm sure they're
gonna have their bad days and I think
the lack of transparency with the media
and the lack of willing has to show like
the lighter side of the New England over
the years leaves a lot of people
assuming and certainly one thing I
appreciated about watching that offense
was like if Bill got in a meeting
anybody should get you know it on Monday
morning and that included like Tom or
Jules or like the premier players right
down to the fifty third guy on the
roster and I thought that accountability
was really refreshing and cool and I
know that you know we can put the
relationship under a microscope after
two decades I would challenge almost
anybody to find me another pairing that
could last 20 years so I think we look
at this thing we say what was wrong with
the relationship when we say it every
year but I would look at it from the
other angle and say listen it's kind of
a miracle that these guys were able to
do what they're able to do for 20 years
and now you get to find out for all the
people who have been lusting for the
opportunity to see who you know what
came first chicken or the egg who's more
important I don't know you're gonna be
able to make an honest determination
that's just such a unique situation
people want to hold the bill sing
against them with brown
record but they were getting ready to
leave town and that's never good I've
seen what that's like
firsthand in football with the Rams and
also coaches can grow and I'm sure in 20
years somebody that brilliant and I tell
you what he is absolutely bringing you
to walk around the field and coach every
position better than the position coach
I think that's what separates him I
think he's probably grown I mean the guy
won 11 games with Matt Cassel on the
heels of a big disappointing Super Bowl
loss that's hard for teams to do to come
back off the Superbowl run let alone one
like that and then the loser shoot your
your Superbowl franchise quarterback and
Tom Brady he I think bills battle-tested
and and the Pats have always treated
things like another a different opponent
every week they have to to morph into
something different this year is going
to be a totally different year for them
it's an opponent in of itself
Chris long here in the Rich Eisen show
and then they go one other thing that
you made mention about a football
decision for Brady you you think it
might be very difficult as you know
Patriots fans haven't been around them
maybe for difficult things for Patriots
fans to swallow that the Bucs were a
better football decision than than
sticking with New England but you you
think that that is an accurate
assessment Chris I do I do I mean I
think anybody being being honest here is
looking at that that roster and saying
hey listen I watched the Bucs play a lot
last year which could be maddening with
Jameis um but that defense is very good
and you know and in the run game
bringing pressure I think they're going
to be a top five defense this year
they've done a good job locking up their
rushers which is huge because those
rustlers are going to have more
consistent leads that defense is going
to stand to gain some secure footing by
playing more complimentary football less
turnovers less unpredictability
I mean sudden change is like the
dirtiest word on defense and that's when
you're you're trying to drink water and
you got to rush back on the field and
put your helmet on cuz Jameis do another
Pig and I do like Jameis and I see why
people why it's tantalizing but Tom's
going to give them
more stability so the defense will
improve Oh J Howard's going to improve
Evans Godwin you know they've got a
number of talented individuals on that
offense and I think all they really have
to fix down there the uniforms and
they're gonna reveal new ones in the
next couple days so Tom's got the Jeter
house and he got Godwin's number 12 he
did which is fine yeah which he didn't
have to buy it which is just another
example of rich people getting stuff for
free he just got the twelve a Godwin had
like an incredible season for him a
transformative season for him in the
twelve he just coughed it right up said
I'll take for it yeah yeah you take
number fourteen that's right you imagine
charging the goat for a Jersey I mean
like a mr. screwed up thing if you were
if you were an undrafted free agent you
wanted a number you have to pay tens of
thousands of dollars or a draft tech
right but the goat who's has got Jeter's
mansion he's great maybe you know when
Tom and the family go somewhere maybe
down to Costa Rica leaving Jeter's
mansion clear maybe Godwin gets it for a
weekend maybe you know listen goblins
gonna be made made right here tom is
about the most thoughtful and
accommodating teammate you could have
made right by endzone targets yeah
that's one leg I think Godwin's happy to
work that one over so how many rooms
would you need in the Jeter mansion
Chris in the Jeter mansion I'm not a big
like huge mansion guy right I just need
like a covered porch if tom has a nice
covered porch keep me out of the Sun a
cooler like a Yeti
maybe Trager grill okay sure John like a
hammock would be tremendous maybe down
by the water yeah st. Jeter's burgers I
guess what it's being called about their
Tampa st. Tampa st. Jesus right there it
is huge Wow three thirty thousand square
feet yep don't throw well and 830,000
875 square feet don't cheat him there's
a whole other thing
family home sure Chris long here on the
Rich Eisen show and you mentioned about
this being one of the most unique
obviously offseason ever you have to
figure Cam Newton might have a job right
now if there was an able to ability to
give him a look-see physically
potentially you know you mentioned
Jameis you got a five thousand yard
passer uh as a free agent and a first
overall selection former MVP of the
league with which one would you you know
if you were in any position which one
would you tell you if if I'm if I'm
looking at Jameis or Cam yes sir you
know as a fan I want to see Jameis I
wanted to see Jameis in New England
because it's good TV I want to see
Jameis in Las Vegas I want to see you
know like I want to see Gruden and
Jameis I want to see Bill and Jameis but
you know if cams healthy and that's the
big question that's the unfortunate part
of this thing and he stands to lose and
has lost the most out of almost anybody
the timing of it even on the on the
Panthers and if he'd have had a head
start a couple weeks earlier who knows
you know it's been a game of musical
chairs and as you get older and leak you
see you know in free agency when you're
young and you hit the market for the
first time and as a player my problem I
never hit the market you know the open
market when I was when I was putting up
good numbers so like I never had that
experience but later in free agency you
watch those chairs get you know sat in
and eventually just like that there's
less and less and I can only imagine for
a quarterback who's been an MVP who's
who's put up big numbers who's carried a
franchise and been shorted by that
franchise quite honestly as far as
surrounding him with talent to now his
first chance on the wrong side of 30 do
you know to start somewhere for us where
they might surround him with the right
pieces and it is a game of musical
chairs uh I still like him in LA but
again what what's a physical that's
passed in Atlanta to a doctor in LA you
know with the Chargers you you know you
saw this with Michael brokers who I
talked to the other day who went to he
was about to sign with Baltimore and
they dig a little deeper
like yeah we we don't want you're
worried about your ankle well he can't
get there in person and I think cams got
a lot of the same issues so I think you
know it's surreal to consider cam being
a backup but he might do that for a year
I think Pittsburgh could be a really
good you know landing spot for him you
never know what Big Ben and his health
in any given year and he's up there in
years so you got to figure out if he's
healthy and then find the right fit yeah
Los Angeles would seem to be a perfect
spot Chris for the Chargers but it's
obvious the Chargers went with the Yolo
route with Brady and and one that didn't
happen they were just gonna go back to
what their plan would have been which is
going to the season with a veteran
steady veteran and I know that that's
like a faint praise for at arad Taylor
but and then go draft somebody six
overall and Herbert I don't mind I mean
like there's gonna be somebody there
that they might really like it six and
you know people said Chicago for cam and
the next thing had a lot of people
befuddled because of what happened last
year in Jacksonville and you know you
might not think you know Nick Foles Cam
Newton obviously Cam's had you know a
more consistent career but then you look
at things like Chicago and Chicago is
running Philly's offense they're running
Kansas City's offense so there's
intricacies that go into this thing and
as you looked at each landing spot you
add in the factor that cam hasn't had a
physical plus the scheme differences and
it's been tough for him you know I hope
to see him come out on the other end on
the Panthers end you know they got Brady
Joe Brady Bridgewater has a relationship
with him and you know Kristin was more
Kristin was better under Center getting
the ball so you know cams not taking
under center snaps I mean yards per
attempt all that went up when when when
you know cam went out and they were
taking snaps under Center so if your
best player on offense is Christian
McCaffrey you got to make a decision at
some point Chris long here on the Rich
Eisen show on
football one for you Chris you know Nick
Foles very well you know obviously
Chicago through your bro
and so what's full is gonna bring to
that quarterback room we keep hearing
pushing Mitchell true Biscay yeah we
keep hearing that phrase well translate
what that all means is I think it's such
a funny word in the NFL as a young guy
to push you you know it's just
competitions good good competition
coaches have their minds made up usually
when they say that you know and I think
Mitch got you know at times it's
unfortunate for him because of the draft
class you know if you're dropping draft
in South five it's hard enough when when
there's Patrick mahomes
that gets picked out you you're always
gonna have that hung over your head for
better for worse that really has nothing
to do with what with Mitch it has
everything to do with who who picked him
but you know Nick if somebody's going to
bring in a tremendous amount of
leadership one of the best leaders I've
ever been around
period and he's gonna be a guy who can
distribute the football within that
system so I think you know you taken a
shot at somebody who's had high highs
you know you saw Nick in Philly chapter
one
record setting with Chip Kelly chapter
two you saw him as the Super Bowl MVP
obviously and then you sell the lows
which were Jacksonville and Earth City
st. Louis Rams in the fishery years
where quarterbacks were not succeeding
and so quarterbacks need context and
need things around them and I think next
one of those guys you can't succeed just
anywhere there's only a few guys who can
do that but if you surround Nick with
the right players and scheme I think
he'll be fine he can handle the pressure
of Chicago nick is unflappable and I
think they've done well on the defensive
side of the ball to Robert Quinn is a
great pickup you know he's only like a
year older and Leonard ployed and coming
off double digits in Dallas he was the
best edge rusher and I like Lawrence a
lot but he was and Rob's gonna do well
on that on that end of the ball as well
because you got Mack on the other side
you got a power rusher you got a speed
rusher I think
Chicago's made some nice moves yeah I
mean they call it an open competition
today both Matt naggy and Ryan pace
coach and general managers it's gonna be
an open transparent competition and that
true Biscay is taking it well as a
competitor well it's your bisque e's
been through everything and i feel for
the guys so i think he's you know this
is gonna make him better one way or the
other he's seen the worst i mean last
year was rock bottom I feel like in a
market like Chicago and I'm pulling for
Mitch but I think Nick eventually wins
that battle because he's just ready for
that and that's the right scheme and I
hope it works out for both guys well I
don't know I mean if Nick wins the
battle that's it for true Biscay I mean
see I mean already you got mahomes is a
Super Bowl MVP and deshaun Watson is an
MVP candidate and neither those guys
needed Nick Foles being brought in to
push or compete I mean no but right the
scheme aspect I don't think they ever
did right by me I don't think that they
catered the spoon to Mitch's strengths
and I know that like hey listen he's a
top five cake why are we catering to his
strengths well I mean that's like that's
a dumb question to ask because here's
the guy you got right um I do think that
you know if you looked at some of the
things they did or didn't do the last
couple years he he could have benefited
from some tweaks within that all offense
I'll just say that and you know I don't
know if he ever gets a second chance if
Nick beats him out but uh but if he wins
if he wins this this battle he's gonna
be better for it I I would I would lean
Nick though Chris thanks for the call
man green light with Chris Long on Apple
podcast and we're all other podcasts can
be gotten I'd love to continue chats on
the regular with you and if you want me
to do a home-and-home on your pot I'm
more than yeah Holman homes are good
good just get the great rich eyes and on
my pot no no problem like that idea
before we go out the door you're over
rating I asked you to send it you did
the reason why is all God look at that a
sterling 400 yeah
Shh is that good is it good oh just wait
some people say if you're not a five
like you know nobody's a five well what
if you're what if you're a 4/5 for Chris
what if you're 44 that's good that's
good at the combine is bad I did nothing
wrong nothing a lot of it did do to
where you live you know the you live in
New York yeah no I live I'm a New Yorker
in Los Angeles
oh you're not you're in LA okay right
the stressful environment - yes
I mean uber drivers are probably
stressed and and they're probably
they're probably just yes they're just
stressed and their rating you down so
again it's not me is what you're saying
it's them it's not a me thing can't be
dude it can't be and I thought I would
be lower than that so when you I'm
actually pretty happy look a lot better
with a four five four four nine dollars
yeah you haven't ever taken the wheel of
the car like Pat McAfee once said he had
to do because the guy was driving too
slow you've never done that though right
no that's a bit aggressive but that's on
par for Pat I'm I'm more liable to just
sit back there and my you know just say
to myself I less talking you know even
if and I hate making people stressed out
so if I'm not about to miss its light
I'll probably just wait and just write
them down okay gotcha quietly rate down
I'll have to take notes Chris you the
man thanks again appreciate it say hi to
your folks and and let's let's keep in
touch
thanks for it take it easy right back
atcha Chris long love that guy at Joel
nine number nine one on twitter and at
la flama Blanca 95 on Instagram